Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich. This is Radiolab and today, well,
stories about confrontation row down, base off smackdown.
We're calling it what's left when you're right. And now at last a.
That title will make sense.
I think it will cause now we have a story about a fight that starts in a cage,
spills over into the human species as a whole.
It turns out in the end to be nested inside the brains of every single one of
us. Oh. And that story comes from our producer pet Walters. Okay,
I'll start it for me with this essay that I read by this guy named Jonathan
Ghoshal. I'm a writer and a fighter. Dad, bad man.
So a few years ago, I'm an English teacher.
I'm sitting in an English department. I'm sitting in the cubicle.
He was a teacher at a small college outside Pittsburgh.
And at the time Jonathan had written some articles, even a couple of books,
but I was still an adjunct, lowly adjunct,
you know the academic equivalent of cheap migrant labor.
I'm pretty low on the totem pole.
So I was sitting there in the cubicle that I share with other adjuncts,
just kind of feeling miserable.
I'm down about my job and then catch a glimpse of movement through the window
and I go to the window and I look out and nurses that across the street where
there used to be a car parts store.
This new business had opened up a mixed martial arts gym.
This cage fighting stuff that you see on TV that they're like the kind where you
can wait where anything goes. Like that guy or anything goes. Yeah, punching,
kicking mean ground and power.
You can climb on top of the guy and punch him in the face until he, he goes out.
Does that stuff is just too raw? Well,
I hadn't been watching it a guiltily and very much in the closet for about 15
years. I knew it was wrong. I watched it in the way that most men watch porn.
You know, my wife would walk into the room and I was watching.
I really quickly turned the channel then out there they were.
He's huge muscle bound dudes in the picture window right across the street there
in the cage, right. And each other they're tackling,
they're fighting on the ground. And as he watches them, day after day,
I start to envy them.
No,
I am the bravery and the way they just seemed so alive while I was in my cube
rotting. And so one day he decides, uh, I decided to do it.
I'm going over there. No, I'm not a tough guy. I'm an English professor.
I'd never been in a fight before, but I wanted to try to do a brave thing.
Did you, did you tell your wife? Yeah. Yeah. Um,
and what was your Western reaction? This is almost perfect. Paraphrase.
He said you will be killed. You have no skills. Yeah. It kinda hurts.
It hurts to find out. Your wife has no respect for you're fighting prowess,
but that doesn't stop him. No, that's training sparring with other beginners.
And this is how it all goes down. Um,
maybe I'm four months into my training,
let's say I'm about four months into my training and I feel like I'm starting to
get the hang of things.
I'm starting to feel more confident and I'm doing pretty well against the other
beginners in, in, in the sort of the weaker guys in the gym. Oh.
So one day I go into the gym and in turns I'm going to,
I'm going to spar this guy named named nick.
And I'm a little concerned about it because he's been at the gym longer than me,
but I'm not all that concerned because I've watched nick,
we all watch each other in the gym and he's just not an athlete.
He even says this himself. He's, he's a kind of a Klutzy guy. Uh,
he's awkward in his movements, a little bit, a little bit stiff.
And I felt that just like athletically, I stacked up very well with him.
I was faster than him. I thought I'd get around better. And so, you know,
we'd go into the cage and the bell rings and you know,
we go to the center of the cage and we engage and again,
I'm feeling confident and then he punches me hard in the face.
Then you hit them again.
The punches keep coming. Jab, Cross, Jab, Cross, Jab, cross, Hook. He doesn't,
Bobby,
he doesn't weave. He doesn't dance. He's right there in front of you.
You should be able to hit him. But I can't.
He's as hammering me. Finally the Bell Rings and uh,
I go collapse in one of the chairs and my headache is already thudding in my
brain. And I say to myself, well, that seals it. The, the,
the 40 Raymond hypothesis has to be true.
40 Raymond hypothesis has to be four 40. Oh,
the 40 Raymond. Yeah. So, okay, what's the right question?
That's 40 Raymond hypothesis. Okay.
So 40 and Raymond are these French researchers.
So before we get down to the two French researchers, you could say that Nick,
that Guy Jonathan,
because the lefty, nick is a lefty.
Jonathan is a righty in this conflict between lefties and righties.
It goes way back. Oh yeah, absolutely. Just ask
David Wohlman. I'm an author and journalist in Portland, Oregon.
You're right handed, right? No, I am very lefthanded like you wanted to kill me.
I was trying to, I was trying to get it out that way. Like if that man defends,
you know, against crime. David is a defender of lefties everywhere.
I am a strong lefthander.
If you look at the Edinburgh handedness inventory, I'm like a 10 out of 10.
I did it. I'm a very strong right hand. Like, uh,
I got all like a perfect score for right handedness. Okay,
well our friendship is over now, David, I kinda joking,
but he actually wrote this whole book called a lefthanded turn around the world
because growing up as a kid in a family of right handers,
David says he always felt a little different, or as his family used to put it,
you're special. And this is,
this is some little extra sprinkle of specialness in you. Luckily they're,
they're not, uh, you know,
they didn't grow up in the Middle Ages and think that I was cursed by the devil
and therefore I'm lefthanded because throughout the ages and pretty much
throughout every culture, uh, left-handers were perceived as evil and sinister.
In fact, the words industry itself is derived from a Latin word,
which means on the left side and in English, when we say something is correct,
we say it's right. You know, in the Bible,
God always doing really nice and benevolent things with the right hand and not
so nice or benevolent things with the left hand,
everything left is all of these ugly or lesser or different or are worrisome.
And the presumption was that if this was not, um,
the result of a curse by it from the devil,
then this was the result of poor parenting or poor posture.
But we know now that now it's genetic.
When you do a genetic study and you look at parents, here's how it plays out.
If you have two right handed parents,
their chance of having a lefthander is about nine and a half percent.
If you have one ready one lefty parents, the odds do go up.
Now you've got 20% almost 20% chance then to south parents have a 26% chance of
delivering into the world at South Park.
And if you add up those chances and look out across the entire human species,
we are about 90% right-handed. 10% lefthanded.
90% of people are right handers, which brings us back to Borean Raymond.
So 40 in Raymond realize that left handedness is a sort of evolutionary mystery.
Jonathan says it's a mystery,
at least in part because lefthanded this seems to come with some disadvantages.
It's associated with all these negative health outcomes and I actually wrote a
few of them down. Higher risk of schizophrenia, immune deficiency,
epilepsy, learning disabilities, spinal deformity, ADHD, alcoholism,
dyslexia, psychopathy room's disease. It's not even a complete list.
So weight lefties have a higher incidents of all of these things. Yeah,
significant. How much higher? Like a TD bit higher or any bit teeny. Vinny,
bit like a really teeny bit. But evolution works on Teeny bits, right?
So if there are significant health costs of being left handed,
why hasn't natural selection trimmed away? Why do we still have lefties at all?
That's the puzzle and the 14 Raymond hypothesis is that we still have lefties in
the world because they have an advantage in one arena. Combat,
which is what Jonathan realized in the ring with Nick,
you get very used to fighting right handers.
You get used to where the punches are coming from and then you face the
left-hander and they do everything backwards and you have to develop basically a
whole different approach to, to fighting. And if you go back
to a time when wars were won and lost largely because of hand to hand combat,
whether with fifths or spears or with clubs or whatever,
maybe the ancient lefties, like nick had a little edge
maybe to survival advantage of battling lefthanded washed out those survival
costs associated with being lefthanded
14 Raymond came up with this prediction of prediction based on their idea that
if lefthanded this is somehow linked to fighting prowess,
then wherever they go in the world,
they will find that the most violence societies have the highest proportion of
lefties. How would they define violent? Like over time,
the number of wars or why? Rumors of wars, homicide, that kind of thing. I see.
Huh. So they dug up some data on violent and left handedness in three different
tribal societies.
Then they went out and did their own field research and five other groups and
they find this beautiful correlation. The least violence,
violence society in their sample had 3% lefthanders.
The most violence societies in their sample tribal societies in New Guinea that
were notoriously violent had rates of left handedness a about 25 or 30% Whoa,
whoa. Yeah. She was a sweet,
credible many lefties and yes, as us I guess. Yeah. Wow.
So seem to be true. Case closed.
No, no. Here's the thing.
That tribe from Papa New Guinea that had three times as many lefties as you
would expect. That was data that they looked up in the library,
but when some other scientists actually went in the field and checked it,
they found
no evidence that lefties were overrepresented in his tribe.
It wasn't heavily lefty. According to this study.
They just didn't find any evidence that lefties were overrepresented.
I am disappointed because this was a very cool idea. I was disappointed too,
but I think we can salvage it.
Did the original user,
Jonathan had an idea of this hour after nick knocked him out.
He thought maybe looking at real battles, real violence.
Maybe that was where Valerie and Raymond went wrong. Maybe left.
The jeans are maintained more through success in the play,
fights of sports, then an actual no holds barred violence.
Maybe it's about sports, not war. In fact,
actually lefties have long been known for doing better at the,
at all kinds of different sports. Tennis, boxing, baseball.
We look at a Northwestern study, Chad,
which found that 50% of the top players in baseball did highest rbis.
The best pitchers weight, 50% are lefties. Yes.
And you see the same over representation of lefties in any sport that's got a
one on one component, you know, a face off kind of thing.
The only scientific question you need to ask is
do athletes have more children? Oh wait a second.
So you're saying all those lefty pitchers that are really good and that screw up
the right handed hitters. Maybe they're having so many kids. Yeah.
And that's what keeps that 10% 10% well, sorta. Yeah. So,
but we can check this. We can have lefty Gomez, New York.
Giant left-hander has 16 children.
So people [inaudible] people have actually looked into this, you know,
they've looked into it to do athletes do better with the ladies and the evidence
is pretty strong that they do a [inaudible].
You went to [inaudible] high school and college, I noticed that like Duh Duh,
you don't need a scientist to tell you that and so,
but you have to count your babies count the babies or you,
they counting the babies early or you can or you count the reproductive
opportunities. What do you mean? Like how many dates they go on? Yeah, exactly.
How many sex partners they have. Why not count the babies?
You don't want to count the baby? Well,
because we live in an era of birth control now, so it's, it's a,
in the environments in which these traits evolved, there was,
there were no reliable means of birth control.
So we use reproductive opportunities as a proxy for reproductive rights.
And then, okay, it's starting to make sense to me now.
How could I lovingly say that sounds like total garbage.
You think David would love this idea? He's the lover of lefties.
But now it's just, there's too much biology at play here. Uh,
so and too much ancient prehistoric biology at play for this to matter as much
as your dear English professor friend wants it to matter.
But here's, here's the thing,
whether or not this hasn't been proven scientifically, personally,
I know it's true.
I know it's true because I experienced it.
I know it's true in a way that statistics can't touch. You know,
I know it's true from being in that cage,
having the undoubtable truth just pounded into my brain literally by my friend
neck. You know, I, I know it's true.
Yeah. I mean it's so fun.
These kind of things are so fun cause it's so easy, right? I mean,
who doesn't love an easy answer,
but it seems so far fetched and maybe that makes me a little bit of a wet
blanket. But after this year, plus investigating this topic,
David says about halfway through writing his book,
this whole handedness puzzle kind of flipped for him.
Instead of worrying about why lefties have stuck around,
he started to wonder about that 90 10 number cut.
Like why inhumans de lefties only make up 10% of the population when in pretty
much every other creature on earth, this asymmetry is random. In other words,
it's a coin flip.
Whether a monkey in South America is going to be left or right handed.
Several studies have shown that it's about 50 50 in cats. See Mister for dogs,
people have looked at mice, toads, various kinds of birds,
and all of them have a pretty even split.
It looks like what is unique to humanity is the 90 10 so how did we end up at 90
10 well,
one of the strongest theories for the origins of handedness hooks hen is onto
left hemisphere dominance for speech. The idea says,
David is that humans are way back in the day.
So these would be like early humans. Prehuman ancestors were 50 50 so that is,
they were 50% righty. They were 50% left.
You like all the other animals in the forest.
So the things that our brains were doing back then were also even on both sides.
So the motor cortex on the left controlled the right hand as it still does.
The motor control on the right controls the left hand as it still does,
but then at some point in our evolutionary history,
the language begins to develop and there was this shift in brain organization.
Yeah, the part of the brain that controls speech,
I don't know why this happened,
but it began to move over to the left side of our brain according to one theory.
That shift ended up making the left side of our brains better at motor control.
Because think about what speech is. I'm going to say,
let's pick a pair of pickled peppers, my tongue,
my lips, my teeth are all in a middly of complex motion there.
That is all about motor control.
So the left side of my brain is doing that and it's getting bigger and stronger.
As the species gets more and more speechy,
it gets more and more left brain or right hand.
As you're saying that a speech grows on our left side.
The motor cortex grows on our left side and since the left motor cortex controls
do you
the end result is a bias to the right. Yes, but weirdly buried, similar,
deep in our DNA still is this gene that confers the chance to become a lefthand
in which results in about 10% of the population being lefties.
But they're not dwindling though. They just seem to stick there. Well,
they don't seem to be dwindling in the, in the blink of an eye that is not I'm,
we've been looking at dwindling, but do you know what I mean?
Or whatever. Maybe there's just, you know,
you're just still around because you're like the vestige of, of,
of what we used to be. Thank you. Thank you. I'll call my,
as soon as my kids are old enough to, I'll tell them that the daddy's a vestige,
which sort of brought us back to our original question,
like why aren't lefties dwindling? And when we pushed David,
here's what he finally said.
I would argue because I'm a lefty and a strong lefthanders. So you know, um,
take many, many grains of salt. You're arguing from pride. We understand,
of course. No, I will pride in a little bit of research,
but I would argue that a splash of diversity within the brain as far as brain
organization has had a cumulative beneficial effect for our species.
Now, if you, how exactly does he mean? Well, because if conditions on earth,
true change radically nature just likes to have a little variety in the,
in the gene pool.
So if everyone's doing really well with one set of genes and the situation
changes drastically, right? You don't want everybody to get sick and die.
So in variety there is a slightly heightened chance of survival.
I think it's a subtle advantage to the population, but I think,
I think there's a beauty to it. Nevertheless,
lefties are coming at the world from a slightly different angle.
But this puts,
David didn't kind of a weird spot because even if lefties don't dwindle away,
if sports are brain diversity or some other random reason keeps them around,
they'll always be the few. You know as I said in the book,
I don't think this is caused for for the next March on Washington, but,
but lefties are their own special minority group.
Unless you are Eric [inaudible] Coco.
He was, yes. Somehow I knew you guys would go for the parrot.
As it turns out,
parrots seem to be I it's 90% left handed or left footed or left Claude left
talent, whatever. I just supposed to call it rubber band.
Went to visit this artist named Hunt Sloan in boot rescues and a lot of parents
cockatiel whose name is Crayola and we tested 11 of his parents.
So they told us that their test that they've used before is he put a piece of
food on the table or in a platform and whichever foot they pick it up here is
their preferred foot. Well that makes sense. Right. Would walk up to Kay,
this is Clive. Hi Greet.
The parents want to give you a potato chip present with our treat and then we
would wait to see what he did. I lefty, we never, we have a left.
They went up to another cage and if the same thing I left it left, left foot,
another left g and then the end left again.
The final count was, okay, let's do our final tally with what?
Nine nine two two two one nine lefty, two righty.
And one went both ways. Most of that is close to 90% close to. Yes.
If David was a parent would have felt right at home.
But why do you suppose parents are 90 to 10 the other way? I have no idea.
I don't think anybody knows that. Uh,
on the other.
Hi. Thank you
Ronnie. Hi.
Where's this? We can say as me, him,
nothing there on there. Before we close, we have a little sad news.
Our producer, Pat Walters,
carrot Walters will be moving on moving to the left coast after the show.
If you listened to this show over the last few years,
you've heard all kinds of wonderfully strange and diverse tails.
Yeah.
It'd taken pat to all kinds of different places and put them in all kinds of
different wounds. And you hate to lose the rainbow, you know, he is one himself.
Definitely. Definitely Pat, we love you. We wish you the very,
very best out there.